Rhonda Sanders chose to go to San
Francisco as he makes his campaign for
presidency you look around the city is
not vibrant anymore it's really
collapsed because of leftist policies
and the wreckage has really really been
sad to see and so I've seen so many
businesses boarded up I've seen so much
uh riffraff just running around and it
just shows you these policies matter
leadership matters they are doing it
wrong here I really like this look
fabulous observation tour I like this
look of Ron DeSantis being out in The
Fray in front of this graffitied up
building all this trash on the street I
wish we saw more of the delivery here